- Bentornato a "Capire l'Informazione e il Calcolo Quantistico." Mi chiamo John Watrous, e sono il Direttore Tecnico
per l'Educazione di IBM Quantum.
Questa è la quinta lezione della serie, ed è la prima lezione nella
seconda unità della serie, che riguarda gli Algoritmi Quantistici.
In questa unità, esamineremo
i vantaggi computazionali dell'informazione quantistica, cioè, daremo uno
sguardo a quello che possiamo fare
con i computer quantistici e i vantaggi che i computer quantistici potrebbero potenzialmente avere
rispetto ai computer classici.
Ci concentreremo su quello che possiamo fare con un singolo computer quantistico al contrario di un contesto distribuito,
ad esempio,
dove più computer quantistici interagiscono su una rete di qualche tipo.
Ci sono, in effetti, vantaggi quantistici da trovare in contesti distribuiti, dove entrano in gioco comunicazione e
crittografia,
ma non parleremo di queste cose
in questa unità.
Questa unità riguarda algoritmi quantistici in esecuzione su singoli computer quantistici.
Iniziamo con una domanda naturale. Quali vantaggi potrebbe potenzialmente offrire un computer
quantistico?
Il principale è che i computer quantistici potrebbero fornire soluzioni più rapide ad alcuni problemi computazionali.
Il tempo è prezioso, e sebbene i computer che
usiamo ogni giorno siano abbastanza veloci, sono ancora troppo lenti
per risolvere certi problemi computazionali solo a causa della difficoltà
computazionale intrinseca di quei problemi.
Questa potenzialità che i computer quantistici potrebbero permetterci di risolvere problemi che i computer classici
sono troppo lenti per risolvere
è davvero ciò che ha guidato
la ricerca sugli algoritmi quantistici negli ultimi decenni.
Ci sono altre risorse computazionali
oltre al tempo che possono essere considerate, come la quantità di memoria del computer necessaria per i calcoli,
ma i computer quantistici non possono
offrire troppi risparmi in termini di memoria, come risulta, e la memoria del computer classico è abbastanza economica
particolarmente rispetto alla memoria quantistica. Quindi non c'è
molta speranza qui.
Potremmo anche pensare ad altre risorse come la quantità di energia
necessaria per il calcolo, ma in realtà non hai bisogno di molta energia
per calcolare classicamente, particolarmente se sei
disposto a rallentare le cose.
Quindi è davvero il tempo
richiesto per i calcoli, che è la nostra attenzione principale.
Ecco una panoramica della lezione, che riguarda un modello specifico
di calcolo noto come il modello query.
Puoi pensare a questo modello come una specie di piatto di Petri per sviluppare idee algoritmiche, sia quantistiche che classiche.
Non è inteso come un modello pratico che descrive i tipi
di problemi computazionali che incontriamo nella vita reale.
Ci allontaneremo dal modello query nelle lezioni successive di questa unità e ci concentreremo invece su modelli motivati da nozioni più pratiche
di calcolo,
ma il modello query è un
ottimo punto di partenza.
È un modello semplice che ci permette di esplorare il
potenziale dei computer quantistici senza che molti dettagli tecnici si mettano in mezzo,
e ci permette anche di isolare alcune delle
idee davvero importanti dietro il calcolo quantistico e come funziona.
Il calcolo quantistico si è, in effetti, sviluppato per la prima volta all'interno di questo modello, e le idee sviluppate al suo interno hanno ispirato molto direttamente
importanti algoritmi quantistici
come l'algoritmo di Shor per la fattorizzazione.
Nella prima sezione della lezione, daremo uno sguardo specificamente a cos'è il modello query di calcolo,
e nella seconda, terza
e quarta sezione, discuteremo tre
algoritmi quantistici di query, vale a dire l'algoritmo di Deutsch,
l'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa,
e l'algoritmo di Simon, che rivelano vantaggi sempre più
impressionanti
dei computer quantistici
rispetto ai computer classici all'interno del modello query di calcolo.
Per spiegare il modello query di calcolo, iniziamo prima con una
astrazione più standard di calcolo.
Ecco un'immagine che
rappresenta un calcolo in termini molto semplici e basilari.
Abbiamo un input, che di solito prende la
forma di una stringa binaria, sebbene potremmo usare altri
simboli se volessimo.
L'input viene fornito al calcolo, che è rappresentato da un
rettangolo blu in questa immagine,
e il risultato del calcolo è che viene prodotto un output, e di nuovo, quello è più
tipicamente una stringa binaria.
Ovviamente, questa immagine
non è affatto specifica su come funziona il calcolo stesso.
Possiamo formulare diversi
modelli computazionali specifici per farlo, come macchine di Turing
e circuit booleani,
o circuit quantistici se stiamo pensando al
calcolo quantistico.
È vero che questa immagine
non rappresenta il fatto che molti dei
computer che usiamo ogni giorno ricevono continuamente
input e producono output,
essenzialmente interagendo con noi e con altri computer attraverso
internet, ad esempio.
Ma non stiamo cercando di rappresentare
quelle interazioni qui.
Questo riguarda la modellazione
di compiti computazionali isolati.
Ad esempio, l'input potrebbe essere la
codifica binaria di un numero o una rappresentazione di una matrice
o una descrizione di una molecola o davvero qualsiasi altra cosa abbiamo in mente, e c'è un compito computazionale
che viene eseguito su quell'input da solo.
Il punto chiave qui è
che l'intero input viene fornito al calcolo, e nulla sull'
input è nascosto.
Il modello query di
calcolo funziona diversamente.
Nel modello query, l'input viene reso disponibile
nella forma di una funzione a cui il calcolo può
accedere facendo query,
o in altre parole, valutando la funzione
su diversi input.
Qui puoi vedere che è rappresentato
nella forma di un'immagine.
Simile a quello che avevamo prima, il calcolo è rappresentato
da un rettangolo blu, ma invece di ricevere un input direttamente
nella forma di una stringa
di bit, ad esempio, accede all'input effettivamente facendo domande
e ricevendo risposte.
A volte usiamo i
termini oracolo e scatola nera per riferirci al meccanismo
che fornisce l'input.
C'è una distinzione tra
oracolo e scatola nera nella teoria della complessità, ma non sarà affatto rilevante per gli scopi di questa discussione.
In ogni caso, questi termini sono intesi
a trasmettere l'idea di base.
Nell'antica Grecia, potevi
andare da un oracolo, come l'Oracolo di Delfi,
e porre una domanda importante,
e l'oracolo avrebbe risposto
a quella specifica domanda, ma certamente non ti avrebbe detto tutto quello che sapeva.
In modo simile, quando
pensiamo a una scatola nera, abbiamo in mente una sorta di processo o sistema
dove possiamo scegliere cosa vi entra e possiamo vedere cosa esce, ma non abbiamo alcuna comprensione
del suo funzionamento interno.
E questo è il caso qui. L'input al problema
prende la forma di una funzione, e tutto quello che possiamo fare è
valutare quella funzione,
ma altrimenti, non abbiamo
nessuna conoscenza o comprensione di come funziona.
Per tutta la lezione,
riserveremo la lettera f per la funzione che
rappresenta l'input, e faremo l'assunzione
che prenda sempre la
forma che vedi qui.
Sigma indica l'alfabeto binario, quindi f è una funzione da stringhe
di bit a stringhe di bit,
e nello specifico, assumeremo
che l'input a f sia una stringa di bit di lunghezza n, e l'output sia una stringa
di bit di lunghezza m,
dove n e m sono interi positivi.
Per problemi diversi, avremo
restrizioni su n e m, ma in tutti i casi, la funzione di input prenderà
una forma come questa.
Quando diciamo che un
calcolo fa una query, intendiamo che la
funzione f viene valutata una volta,
cioè, una qualche stringa x di lunghezza N viene selezionata dal calcolo, e la stringa f di x viene
poi resa disponibile
dall'oracolo o dalla scatola nera. E infine, il modo molto semplice in cui misuriamo il costo computazionale
di un algoritmo query è contare quante query richiede.
Quindi, sebbene sia vero che
siamo davvero più interessati a quanto tempo richiedono i calcoli, quando studiamo il modello query,
generalmente manteniamo le cose
semplici e contiamo solo le query, e questo è quello che faremo in questa lezione.
Ora, diamo uno sguardo a
alcuni esempi di problemi query, cioè problemi computazionali nel modello query,
e qui, tra l'altro, descriverò solo
i problemi stessi, e a questo punto, non dirò nulla
su come risolverli.
Il primo problema è il problema OR.
In questo caso, l'input è una funzione
da n bit a solo 1 bit, quindi m è uguale a 1 per questo problema,
e l'output richiesto per
il problema è 1 o 0.
Se c'è una qualche stringa di n bit x per cui f di x è uguale a 1, allora la risposta corretta è 1,
e altrimenti, se f di x è
sempre 0 per ogni stringa x, allora la risposta corretta è 0.
Quindi se pensiamo alla funzione f come fornirci accesso casuale a due alla n bit, uno per ogni stringa x di n bit,
allora quello che chiede
è l'OR di quei bit, ed è per questo che si chiama problema OR.
Un altro esempio è il problema della parità, che è simile al problema OR tranne che chiede la parità,
o in altre parole, l'OR esclusivo di tutti i valori di output
a singolo bit della funzione.
Un altro modo per dirlo è
che la risposta corretta è 0 se il numero di stringhe di n bit x per cui f di x è uguale a 1 è pari,
e la risposta corretta è
1 se quel numero è dispari.
Un esempio di un problema dove m non è necessariamente uguale a 1 è il problema del minimo.
Qui, la funzione f prende la solita forma, e non ci sono restrizioni su n e m,
e la risposta corretta è qualsiasi valore di output
della funzione che viene prima nell'ordinamento lessicografico
o dizionario
delle stringhe binarie. In alternativa, se vuoi
pensare alle stringhe di lunghezza m come rappresentanti interi non negativi in notazione binaria,
allora la risposta corretta
è il valore più piccolo possibile o minimo che
esce da questa funzione.
A volte consideriamo anche problemi query dove abbiamo una promise
sulla funzione di input, o in altre parole, qualche
tipo di garanzia su di essa,
e non ci preoccupiamo delle funzioni che non soddisfano quella promise.
Le funzioni che non soddisfano la promise sono considerate come input "don't care".
E non siamo responsabili di quello che succede su quegli input.
Ecco un esempio di un problema query con una promise chiamato ricerca unica.
È correlato al problema OR,
ma è diverso.
La funzione di input ha la stessa
forma del problema OR, ovvero prende
stringhe di n bit a bit.
Questa volta, ci viene promesso che
c'è esattamente una stringa Z che causa f a valutare a 1,
con f di x uguale a 0
per ogni stringa x diversa da z, e l'output corretto
è questa stringa unica z.
Ovviamente, ci sono
scelte per la funzione f che non soddisfano questa condizione, ma non poniamo alcun requisito
sugli algoritmi per questo problema quando vengono fornite tali
funzioni come input.
Ci interessano solo le funzioni che soddisfano la promise.
Ora, tutti e quattro i
problemi che ho appena menzionato sono problemi abbastanza naturali, nel senso che è facile spiegarli,
ed è facile immaginare situazioni in cui potrebbe sorgere la necessità di risolverli, ma alcuni problemi query
non sono affatto così.
In effetti, a volte consideriamo problemi query altamente
artificiosi, dove è difficile immaginare che qualcuno voglia mai
effettivamente risolverli.
Il problema di Simon, che vedremo
più avanti nella lezione, cade in parte in questa categoria, ma ce ne sono altri
che sono molto peggiori in un certo senso, ma, ciononostante, si rivelano abbastanza importanti per lo studio del modello query.
Non studiamo questi problemi perché vogliamo necessariamente
risolverli in pratica.
Il modo in cui puoi pensarci è che stiamo cercando
degli estremi di vario tipo,
in particolare, quando stiamo lavorando all'interno
di questo piatto di Petri di un modello, un modo naturale per esplorare
le idee algoritmiche quantistiche
è formulare problemi altamente artificiosi, dove possiamo meglio sfruttare il
potere dei computer quantistici.
E questo può effettivamente
fare molta luce su come i computer quantistici
possono potenzialmente essere utili in contesti più pratici.
Possiamo formalizzare la nozione
di una query in modi diversi a seconda del modello computazionale
con cui stiamo lavorando.
Ad esempio, nel modello della macchina di Turing
di calcolo, di cui non abbiamo parlato e non entreremo in questa serie,
c'è un certo modo di
formalizzare la nozione di una query che ha senso per quel modello.
Per i modelli di circuit, definiamo tipi speciali di
gate chiamati gate di query, e questo è come le query
sono formalmente rappresentate.
Per i circuit booleani, c'è un modo molto semplice per farlo, che è semplicemente immaginare
che abbiamo gate di query
che valutano la funzione di input direttamente, come puoi vedere qui sullo schermo.
L'idea è che possiamo
usare questi gate di query per costruire circuit che risolvono qualsiasi
problema che stiamo esaminando,
e per funzionare correttamente, i circuit devono dare la risposta giusta per qualsiasi funzione di input f viene data,
assumendo che soddisfi la promise nel caso di un problema promise.
Ecco un semplice esempio
di un circuit booleano che risolve il problema della parità
quando n è uguale a 1,
quindi la funzione di input f è da
1 bit a 1 bit in questo caso.
Quello che fa questo circuit è valutare la funzione
f sugli input 0 e 1 usando questi due gate di query.
Poi inserisce i due valori di output che
ottiene dai gate di query nel circuit booleano della lezione tre che calcola l'XOR,
che è la stessa cosa della parità.
Per essere chiari, questi due
valori di input qui non sono input del problema,
ovvero il problema della parità,
quando lavoriamo con il modello query, l'input del problema
è la funzione f, e dovresti pensare a questi
due input nel circuit
come valori
hard-coded che non cambiano mai, sono essenzialmente parte dell'algoritmo.
Vogliamo calcolare l'XOR di f 0 e f 1, quindi inizializziamo questi
due fili in questo modo
per farlo funzionare. Abbiamo usato due gate di query
qui, questo e questo,
e quindi l'algoritmo rappresentato
da questo circuit booleano fa due query, e se pensiamo al
problema della parità per un momento
per funzioni da un bit a un bit, vediamo che è assolutamente necessario per qualsiasi circuit booleano
che risolva questo problema
fare almeno due query.
Se fai solo una query così da conoscere solo un
valore di output della funzione f e non l'altro, in realtà non hai
nessuna informazione
sulla parità, perché l'altro valore di output
potrebbe ugualmente essere 0 o 1, portando a entrambe le due possibili soluzioni
del problema. Quindi in termini di numero
di query che fa, questo circuit booleano è il migliore possibile
per il problema della parità
quando n è uguale a 1.
C'è un altro punto sui gate di query che vale la pena menzionare prima di andare avanti, ed è che quando stiamo progettando e analizzando algoritmi query,
non ci preoccupiamo affatto di come
vengono implementati i gate di query.
Si assume che questi
gate di query ci vengano dati, e la difficoltà di costruirli non è nostra preoccupazione.
Puoi pensare ai
gate di query stessi come all'input se vuoi, e non è nostro compito creare l'input, stiamo solo cercando di
risolvere un particolare problema
dato l'input. Ovviamente, quando f è una funzione
da un bit a un bit, ci sono solo quattro possibili scelte,
e sarebbe abbastanza facile
implementarne una qualsiasi, ma in generale, per funzioni
con molti bit di input,
potrebbe essere estremamente difficile implementare gate di query
per quelle funzioni.
Per essere chiari, questo non
vuol dire che la questione di come vengono implementati i gate di query non sia importante, ma piuttosto che non è considerata
come parte del costo
di un algoritmo query.
Questo è coerente con l'idea che questo non riguarda davvero il calcolo pratico o la costruzione di circuit di per sé,
riguarda il lavorare all'interno
di un quadro teorico che ci dice cose interessanti
sul calcolo.
Avremo altro da dire su questo quando facciamo il salto da questo modello a un modello più standard di calcolo, e questo è principalmente quello di cui parlerà la prossima lezione,
la Lezione 6.
Ora rivolgiamo la nostra attenzione
ai circuit quantistici.
Per i circuit quantistici, cambieremo la
definizione dei gate di query per renderli unitari.
Vogliamo poter fare
query all'interno di circuit quantistici e farle operare
linearmente sugli stati quantistici
così da poter effettivamente
fare query in sovrapposizione.
Potrebbe sembrare che stiamo
spostando i paletti, per così dire, cambiando il significato di query rispetto a quello che abbiamo appena
visto per i circuit booleani,
ma c'è una giustificazione per questo che discuteremo in più
dettaglio nella prossima lezione.
Per ora, è solo una definizione.
Nello specifico, la
definizione è la seguente, data qualsiasi funzione f della
stessa forma di prima,
ovvero che mappa stringhe di n bit
a stringhe di m bit, il gate di query Uf agisce su n + m qubit
ed è definito dall'
azione descritta qui sugli stati della base standard.
Vedremo tra poco una figura
che rappresenta questa definizione, ma prima, chiarisco la notazione
che viene usata qui,
ovvero che ogni volta che
usiamo il simbolo per l'XOR come operazione tra due
stringhe della stessa lunghezza,
ci riferiamo all'
OR esclusivo bit per bit, e qui puoi vedere un esempio.
Nella definizione, abbiamo che sia y che f di
x sono stringhe di lunghezza m, quindi questa stringa qui
rappresenta la stringa che otteniamo
facendo l'XOR di quelle due stringhe
insieme, un bit alla volta, ed ecco il diagramma
che spiega come funzionano questi gate.
Gli n qubit in alto corrispondono
all'argomento della funzione.
E quando iniziano
in uno stato della base standard, cat x in questo diagramma, quello stato della base standard
passa invariato
e viene echeggiato come parte dell'output.
Gli m qubit in basso corrispondono all'output
della funzione f, e quando iniziano in
qualsiasi stato della base standard,
cat y in questo diagramma, quello che succede è che l'output della funzione f di x viene fatto XOR sulla stringa y.
Questo è quello che succede per
gli stati della base standard, e se vogliamo sapere
cosa succede in generale per altri stati quantistici, usiamo la linearità, come facciamo sempre.
Una ragione per definire i gate di query in questo modo dove echiamo l'input e usiamo l'XOR bit per bit per l'output
è che questi gate sono sempre unitari per qualsiasi scelta della funzione f.
Questa è, in effetti, un'operazione
deterministica.
E se la esprimessimo come matrice per qualsiasi scelta di una funzione F, otterremmo una matrice di permutazione,
ovvero una con un singolo uno in ogni riga e in ogni colonna, e tutte le altre voci uguali a 0.
E le matrici di permutazione
sono sempre unitarie.
In effetti, per questa operazione, otterremo che l'operazione
è il proprio inverso, quindi Uf dager è uguale a Uf.
Se tutto quello che vogliamo fare con questi
gate è valutare f di x per qualche stringa x, è facile,
possiamo semplicemente impostare y
come la stringa di tutti zeri. Quindi quando facciamo l'XOR bit per bit con y, otteniamo solo f di x.
Qui, tra l'altro, puoi vedere la notazione usata per denotare la stringa di tutti zeri.
Sembra 0 alla potenza M, ma non è quello che significa.
Significa la stringa di zeri
di lunghezza uguale a M.
Quando parliamo di
stringhe al contrario di numeri, gli esponenti tipicamente significano che ripetiamo quella stringa
un certo numero di volte,
quindi questo è 0 ripetuto m volte.
È solo un modo conveniente e preciso per descrivere questa stringa.
Ancora una volta, quando stiamo
lavorando con il modello query, non ci preoccupiamo di come
implementare questi gate di query.
È lo stesso problema
che avevamo con i gate di query per i circuit booleani.
Non è nostro compito preparare l'input, ci viene dato l'input nella
forma di questi gate di query.
Farò notare però, che se sappiamo come
implementare la funzione f usando un circuit booleano, allora è possibile tradurre quell'implementazione
abbastanza direttamente in un'implementazione
di circuit quantistico di Uf, e vedremo esattamente come
funziona nella prossima lezione.
Per inciso, è abbastanza semplice creare un circuit booleano
che funziona in questo modo, usando un singolo gate di query classico per la funzione f,
ma è molto diverso dall'avere un'implementazione di circuit quantistico di questo gate unitario.
Il punto, tuttavia, è che
per gli algoritmi query classici, avere un gate di query che funziona in questo modo è, in effetti, equivalente
ad avere un gate di query classico ordinario
per f, nel senso che ognuno può essere implementato usando l'altro.
In questa sezione della lezione, discuteremo l'algoritmo di Deutsch, che è un algoritmo di query quantistico molto semplice, ma è davvero un gioiello.
Questo algoritmo viene da un articolo del 1985 scritto da David Deutsch, che è stato uno dei primissimi a lavorare sulle
fondamenta teoriche del calcolo quantistico.
L'algoritmo stesso rappresenta una parte molto piccola
dell'articolo del 1985 di Deutsch, e in realtà,
l'algoritmo che chiamiamo ora
l'algoritmo di Deutsch è in realtà una versione migliorata dell'algoritmo che Deutsch descrisse.
Fornisce un esempio molto modesto di come i computer quantistici possano
offrire vantaggi computazionali, ma bisogna pur cominciare da qualche parte,
ed è stato davvero un'importante scintilla che ha dato il via alle cose.
L'algoritmo di Deutsch risolve un problema query spesso chiamato problema di Deutsch nel contesto del calcolo quantistico,
ma in effetti, non è altro
che il problema della parità per funzioni da un bit a un bit, di cui abbiamo già parlato.
Come abbiamo già visto, ci sono quattro funzioni
da un bit a un bit, e sono descritte qui sullo schermo dalle loro tavole di valori.
La prima e l'ultima di queste
funzioni sono costanti, mentre le due centrali sono bilanciate nel senso che i due
possibili valori di output
appaiono lo stesso numero di volte.
Per le due funzioni costanti,
vediamo che la parità, o in altre parole, l'OR esclusivo dei due output è 0,
e per le due funzioni bilanciate, la parità degli output è 1.
Quindi un modo equivalente per
descrivere il problema della parità in questo caso particolare, dove la funzione f prende
un singolo bit come input,
o in altre parole, il problema di Deutsch, è come vedi qui.
L'input è una funzione f
da un bit a un bit, e l'output è 0 se f è costante
e 1 se f è bilanciata.
Come ho già suggerito, ogni algoritmo query classico
che risolve questo problema deve fare almeno due query a f.
Se impari solo uno dei
due valori di output di f, non hai ancora nessuna informazione sulla parità dei due output.
E questo, tra l'altro, è vero
anche per gli algoritmi classici che fanno uso della casualità.
La casualità può a volte essere molto utile per risolvere problemi query, e vedremo un esempio
un po' più avanti nella lezione,
ma la casualità non aiuta qui.
Quindi il nostro algoritmo di prima è ottimale tra gli algoritmi query classici
per il problema di Deutsch.
Ora daremo uno sguardo
all'algoritmo di Deutsch, che è un algoritmo di query quantistico che risolve il problema di Deutsch
usando una singola query.
Ed ecco l'algoritmo
descritto come circuit quantistico.
Abbiamo due qubit
inizializzati come vedi qui, con quello in alto inizializzato a cat 0 e quello in basso inizializzato a cat 1,
e vedremo presto perché inizializziamo questi qubit in questo modo.
Eseguiamo gate Hadamard
sui due qubit, li alimentiamo nel gate di query, eseguiamo un altro gate Hadamard
sul qubit in alto,
e poi lo misuriamo. E la tesi è che
il risultato della misurazione ci dà, con certezza, la
risposta corretta al problema.
Quindi analizziamo il
circuit un passo alla volta per vedere esattamente come funziona.
Lo stato dei due qubit dopo il primo strato di gate Hadamard è il prodotto tensoriale
degli stati meno e più.
Il Hadamard in alto mappa
lo stato 0 in uno stato più, e il Hadamard in basso mappa lo stato 1 in uno stato meno.
Il qubit in alto è a destra, e il qubit in basso è a sinistra, quindi questo è lo stato che otteniamo.
È molto importante che il qubit in basso sia in uno stato meno, tra l'altro, questo non funzionerebbe se inizializzassimo il qubit in basso
a uno stato 0 invece di uno stato 1.
Espanderemo questo stato
a metà, come vedi qui.
La ragione per farlo
non è chiara a questo punto, ma sarà conveniente
tra un attimo.
Ora, pensiamo allo
stato dei due qubit dopo che il gate di query viene eseguito.
Il modo in cui funziona il gate di query
è che calcola F sullo stato della base standard
del qubit in alto e fa XOR del valore
sul qubit in basso,
e qui possiamo vedere il
risultato di farlo.
Per il primo termine, lo stato della base standard
del qubit in alto è 0, quindi f di zero viene fatto XOR
sul qubit in basso,
e funziona per linearità. Ed è simile per il secondo termine, tranne che lo stato della base standard
per il qubit in alto è 1, quindi facciamo XOR di f di 1 sul qubit in basso.
E a questo punto, possiamo
semplificare questa espressione osservando la formula
che puoi vedere qui in basso, che funziona quando a è 0 o 1.
E possiamo semplicemente verificarlo per questi due valori separatamente.
Se a è uguale a 0, allora
fare XOR con a non fa nulla, e meno 1 alla potenza 0 è 1,
quindi i due lati sono uguali. E se a è uguale a 1, otteniamo cat 1 meno cat
0 quando facciamo l'XOR,
che è meno 1
volte cat 0 meno cat 1.
E se usiamo quella formula
per semplificare il nostro stato, dove prendiamo a uguale
a f di 0 a sinistra e a uguale a f di 1 a destra,
otteniamo l'espressione
che vedi qui.
Quindi quando confrontiamo i due
vettori di stato quantistico π1 e π2, vediamo che quello che fa il gate Uf
è effettivamente mettere
uno dei due valori, f di 0 o f di 1, nell'esponente di meno 1,
o in altre parole, nella
fase di ogni termine.
Questa è la ragione per
inizializzare il qubit in basso a 1 e eseguire un gate Hadamard su di esso per creare lo stato meno,
che permette che questo accada.
Si chiama il fenomeno del phase kickback, e ci torneremo tra poco per dargli un'altra occhiata.
È abbastanza importante, e lo vedremo accadere ancora
alcune volte nella lezione, così come nelle lezioni successive.
Ora possiamo semplificare riportando
lo stato meno fuori per ottenere l'espressione
che vedi qui.
Per inciso, è piuttosto
interessante notare che non c'è effettivamente
nessun entanglement qui.
Entrambi questi stati sono stati prodotto. Quindi, beh, l'entanglement
è estremamente interessante,
non capita di
svolgere alcun ruolo in questo particolare algoritmo.
Ripuliamo un po' così da avere un po' più di spazio.
Quello che ora possiamo fare è
estrarre un fattore di meno 1 elevato alla potenza f di zero fuori
per ottenere l'espressione dello
stato che vedi qui.
Noterai che qui abbiamo l'OR esclusivo di f 0 e f 1 nell'esponente di meno 1.
Potremmo aspettarci che sia
f di 1 meno f di 0 perché estraiamo il fattore di meno 1 alla potenza f di 0,
ma otteniamo lo stesso
valore se prendiamo l'XOR perché questi sono bit, e l'unica cosa che conta quando abbiamo un intero nell'esponente di meno 1
è se quell'intero è pari o dispari.
Un altro modo per esprimere questo
stato è come abbiamo qui, dove stiamo semplicemente considerando
i due possibili casi per l'XOR.
e questo è un modo conveniente
per esprimere lo stato mentre consideriamo l'azione
del gate Hadamard finale insieme alla misurazione.
Quando eseguiamo l'ultimo
gate Hadamard sul qubit in alto, lo stato più viene
trasformato in uno stato 0
e lo stato meno viene
trasformato in uno stato 1, che possiamo scrivere in modo più
succinto così.
E infine, quando viene
eseguita la misurazione, il risultato che otteniamo è
quindi l'XOR di f 0 e f 1,
che è il valore che stiamo cercando, e così funziona l'algoritmo di Deutsch.
È abbastanza semplice, e se ci chiediamo cosa
sia che lo fa funzionare, permettendoci di calcolare
la parità di due bit
con una singola query invece di due, una risposta ragionevole è
l'interferenza.
Stiamo effettivamente
calcolando f di 0 e f di 1 allo stesso tempo, perché prima abbiamo eseguito
il gate Hadamard
sul qubit in alto per mettere l'input a f in
una sovrapposizione di 0 e 1.
E attraverso il phase kickback insieme al gate Hadamard finale, stiamo essenzialmente creando un'interferenza costruttiva
per la risposta corretta e un'interferenza distruttiva
per la risposta sbagliata.
Quindi non vediamo la risposta sbagliata, vediamo solo la risposta corretta.
Permettimi ora di dire qualcosa in più sul fenomeno del phase kickback solo per vederlo da
un angolo leggermente diverso.
Prima, osserviamo
questa formula molto semplice dove b e c sono valori binari arbitrari.
In breve, fare XOR di un bit b con il valore 1 è la stessa cosa di eseguire un gate NOT o un'operazione x su b,
e ovviamente, fare XOR
di un bit b con il valore 0 non fa nulla, il che è la stessa cosa di eseguire
l'operazione identità su di esso.
E possiamo esprimere l'operazione identità come x alla potenza 0.
Quindi se eseguiamo un gate Uf su due qubit nello stato della base standard cat b tensoriale cat a,
otteniamo questo risultato, semplicemente per definizione del gate Uf.
e usando la formula, possiamo alternativamente scrivere quello stato come vedi qui.
Questa formula funziona per tutte le scelte di b, quindi per linearità, funziona
per uno stato SI arbitrario
al posto di cat b.
E in particolare, se vogliamo, possiamo scegliere SI come lo stato meno.
E ora ecco il punto chiave di perché il fenomeno del phase x kickback
accade.
È perché l'operazione x
applicata allo stato meno ci dà meno 1 volte lo stato meno.
In termini matematici, diciamo che lo stato meno
è un autovettore dell'operazione x, con autovalore uguale a meno 1.
Gli autovettori e gli autovalori
sono di fondamentale importanza nell'algebra lineare così
come nell'informazione quantistica, e avremo molto
altro da dire su di essi
man mano che la serie continua.
Ma per ora, tutto ciò di cui abbiamo bisogno
è questa semplice formula.
E usandola, possiamo
semplificare il nostro vettore di stato.
E quello lì è essenzialmente il fenomeno del phase
kickback scritto come formula.
Funziona perché lo stato meno
è un autovettore dell'operazione NOT che ha
autovalore meno uno.
Lo generalizzeremo in modo
piuttosto significativo nella Lezione 7, quando ci rivolgeremo alla procedura di stima
della fase, che è ciò che guida
l'algoritmo di fattorizzazione di Shor.
Possiamo vedere questa formula in azione nell'analisi dell'algoritmo di Deutsch
come segue.
Prima del gate di query, il nostro stato è il prodotto tensoriale degli stati meno e più.
Poi applichiamo il gate di query, e espandendo lo stato più
ci dà questo stato.
Ora applichiamo la formula del phase kickback per ottenere questa espressione, e poi l'analisi
continua come prima.
È la stessa di prima, ma qui stiamo solo ponendo
l'attenzione sul phase kickback così da poterlo riconoscere
e possiamo anche essere pronti
per quando viene fuori di nuovo.
Ora ci rivolgeremo all'
algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa, che è un'estensione
dell'algoritmo di Deutsch che risolve effettivamente un paio
di diversi problemi query.
Il vantaggio che
l'algoritmo di Deutsch fornisce rispetto agli algoritmi classici
è abbastanza modesto, una query contro due.
L'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa aumenta un po' quel vantaggio, e spiegherò cosa intendo
quando arriveremo lì.
L'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa può essere visto come un modo naturale e diretto di estendere l'algoritmo di Deutsch
da funzioni da un bit a un bit a funzioni da n bit a un bit, o in altre parole, funzioni di questa forma.
Come circuit quantistico, l'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa
ha questo aspetto, e mi riferirò a questo
come il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa
solo per fare una distinzione minore
tra questo circuit e l'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa stesso perché c'è anche una
fase di post-elaborazione classica.
L'idea è che se eseguiamo
questo circuit e poi misuriamo, otterremo una stringa di n bit y
che ci dice qualcosa
sulla funzione f.
A questo punto, tra l'altro, non ho ancora detto
qual è il problema query che speriamo di
risolvere con questo circuit, sta per arrivare presto.
Ma il punto è che
eseguendo questo circuit, guadagneremo alcune informazioni su f che possono potenzialmente aiutarci
a risolvere problemi query
dove f è l'input. E come ho detto un momento fa, possiamo effettivamente usare questo circuit
per risolvere un paio di
diversi problemi query.
Prima, diamo uno sguardo
al problema query noto come il problema di Deutsch-Jozsa, che è il problema che il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa
era originariamente inteso a risolvere.
Il problema di Deutsch-Jozsa è una generalizzazione del problema di Deutsch, dove l'obiettivo è determinare se una data funzione
è costante o bilanciata.
Nota che questo non è il modo naturale per generalizzare il problema della parità
a funzioni di questa forma.
Qui non stiamo calcolando la parità, il compito è restituire 0 se
la funzione f è costante
e 1 se la funzione f è bilanciata.
La prima cosa da notare su
questo problema è che quando n, il numero di bit di input della
funzione f, è almeno 2,
ci sono scelte per la funzione che non sono né costanti né bilanciate.
Ad esempio, ecco una
funzione da 2 bit a 1 bit che non è né costante né bilanciata.
Non è costante perché entrambi i valori binari
appaiono tra gli output, e non è bilanciata
perché i due valori di output
appaiono con frequenze diverse. 0 appare tre volte
e 1 appare solo una volta.
Per essere bilanciata,
gli output 0 e 1 devono verificarsi esattamente
lo stesso numero di volte.
Il fatto che ci siano funzioni che non sono né costanti né bilanciate quando n è almeno 2 va bene però, considereremo semplicemente
funzioni del genere
come input "don't care". Quindi in altre parole, questo
è un problema promise.
Ed ecco un enunciato preciso
del problema.
Ci viene promesso che la funzione di input f è costante o bilanciata, e l'obiettivo è capire
quale delle due sia.
E non siamo responsabili di quello che succede se l'input
non soddisfa la promise.
L'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa,
che risolve questo problema, consiste prima nell'eseguire il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa e poi restituire 0
se la stringa che
otteniamo dalle misurazioni è la stringa di tutti zeri
e restituire 1 altrimenti.
Un altro modo per dirlo è che restituiamo l'OR dei
bit che misuriamo.
Per analizzare l'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa, sarà utile
prendersi prima qualche momento per pensare ai gate Hadamard.
Possiamo, ovviamente, descrivere l'operazione Hadamard
come una matrice, ma possiamo anche descriverla in termini della sua azione
sugli stati della base standard,
come vedi qui.
Queste due equazioni possono essere
combinate in un'unica equazione, che descrive come funziona un'operazione Hadamard per a che vale uno dei due valori binari,
e possiamo andare un po' oltre ed esprimere quello che
otteniamo come una somma così.
Usando quella formula, possiamo elaborare una formula che descrive come funziona uno strato
di gate Hadamard, dove applichiamo un gate Hadamard
a ciascuno di n qubit.
Qui stiamo descrivendo questa
azione sugli stati della base standard.
E per essere chiari sulla notazione, quando scriviamo h tensoriale n così, dove la parte tensoriale n è un apice,
intendiamo il prodotto tensoriale
n volte di H con se stesso, o in altre parole, n copie
di h tutte in prodotto tensoriale insieme.
Stiamo applicando questa operazione
a uno stato della base standard, e qui sto seguendo la
convenzione che usa Qiskit
per indicizzare le stringhe binarie, solo perché è un buon momento
per introdurre quella convenzione.
Quindi x0 è un bit, x1 è un bit,
e così via con n bit in totale, e i bit sono ordinati
come vedi qui sullo schermo.
Puoi pensare a questo
modo di indicizzare i bit come corrispondente al loro significato se vedi le stringhe come
rappresentanti interi
in notazione binaria, ad esempio.
Se applichiamo un gate Hadamard
a ciascuno di questi qubit, possiamo alternativamente esprimere il risultato come il prodotto tensoriale n volte
di un gate Hadamard applicato a ciascun qubit, e poi possiamo applicare la nostra formula a ciascuno dei fattori del prodotto tensoriale.
E qui stiamo usando
i nomi y e meno 1 fino a y1 al posto di b nella formula,
quindi questi sono valori binari. E ci assicuriamo di usare un nuovo nome ogni volta che usiamo la formula.
Se poi espandiamo tutto usando la multilinearità
dei prodotti tensoriali, otteniamo l'espressione
che vedi qui.
E per essere chiari, le n somme stanno venendo
combinate in una singola somma, ma stiamo ancora sommando
su tutti i possibili valori
per i singoli valori binari.
Ora puliamo le cose così da poter andare un po' oltre.
E il prossimo passo è
introdurre una nuova operazione sulle stringhe chiamata il prodotto punto binario.
Questa è un'operazione su stringhe binarie della stessa lunghezza.
E quello che è il prodotto punto binario di due stringhe x e y
della stessa lunghezza, è l'OR esclusivo o la parità
dei prodotti dei singoli bit.
Potresti anche dire che è l'XOR dell'AND logico dei singoli bit, perché l'AND è la stessa cosa del prodotto
per i valori binari. Un altro modo ancora per describerlo è che è 1 o 0
a seconda se
la somma dei prodotti dei singoli bit è dispari o pari.
È molto simile a un prodotto interno se pensiamo alle stringhe
come vettori di valori binari, ma dove calcoliamo Modulo-2,
o in altre parole, prendiamo il resto dopo la divisione per 2.
Non è davvero un prodotto interno però, quindi merita un nome diverso.
Nel caso in esame, possiamo usare il prodotto punto binario
per rendere la nostra formula per l'azione di uno strato di gate Hadamard
sugli stati della base standard più succinta, ed è qui.
Stiamo usando il fatto che
perché questa somma qui appare nell'esponente di meno 1,
tutto quello che conta è se
è pari o dispari, ma per il resto è fondamentalmente solo una versione condensata
della nostra formula.
Tra l'altro, il prodotto punto binario è simmetrico nel senso che x punto
y e y punto x sono uguali,
quindi siamo liberi di scambiarne l'ordine
ogni volta che è utile.
E ora che abbiamo quella formula, sarà abbastanza facile analizzare
il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa.
Iniziamo con n qubit nello stato 0 e il qubit in basso nello stato 1, ed eseguiamo gate Hadamard
su tutti.
Quindi questo è lo stato degli
n + 1 qubit che otteniamo.
Stiamo trattando il
qubit in basso separatamente perché sarà conveniente.
E di nuovo, vedremo il fenomeno del phase
kickback che accade.
Possiamo ottenere questa espressione
usando la nostra formula, dove sostituiamo la
stringa di tutti zeri per x e sostituiamo x per y,
notando che il prodotto punto binario della stringa di tutti zeri con qualsiasi stringa è 0.
Ma possiamo anche ragionarci direttamente. Stiamo prendendo il prodotto tensoriale di n stati più, e questo è quello che otteniamo,
in prodotto tensoriale con lo stato meno. Poi viene applicato il gate UF, ed è qui che avviene il fenomeno del phase
kickback.
Il valore f di x viene fatto XOR
sullo stato meno per ogni x nella somma.
Quindi f di x viene inserito nella fase.
Ora applichiamo un altro
strato di gate Hadamard solo ai primi n qubit, e questa volta, abbiamo davvero
bisogno della formula.
E quando la applichiamo e facciamo solo un po'
di semplificazione, otteniamo questo stato qui.
Quindi questo è il nostro stato finale appena
prima delle misurazioni.
Lo stato sembra un po' complicato, ed è difficile semplificarlo perché non sappiamo davvero
nulla sulla funzione f.
Ma ricorda, tutto quello che
dobbiamo davvero sapere è se le misurazioni
danno tutte il risultato 0,
perché è quello che determina qual è la nostra risposta al problema.
Se vediamo che ogni
risultato di misurazione è 0, concludiamo che la funzione è costante.
E se uno qualsiasi dei
risultati di misurazione è 1, concludiamo che la funzione è bilanciata.
Quindi calcoliamo la probabilità di ottenere la stringa di tutti zeri
dalle misurazioni.
E risulta essere l'unico risultato che è effettivamente facile da calcolare, perché il prodotto punto binario della stringa di tutti zeri
con qualsiasi stringa è zero. Se esaminiamo il nostro vettore e
pensiamo a cosa succede quando y è la stringa di tutti zeri,
otteniamo questa espressione
qui per la probabilità di ottenere la stringa di tutti zeri
dalle misurazioni.
E considerando i due possibili casi dove f è costante e f è bilanciata, vediamo che la probabilità di
ottenere la stringa di tutti zeri è 1
nel caso che f sia costante, e zero quando f è bilanciata.
Quando f è costante, la somma è 2 alla
n o meno 2 alla n, e dividendo per due alla n
e prendendo il valore assoluto
quadrato si ottiene 1.
E quando f è bilanciata, la somma fa 0.
Questo perché otterremo
più 1 e meno 1 lo stesso numero di volte,
quindi si annullano tutti.
Quindi questo è tutto. L'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa
risolve il problema di Deutsch-Jozsa usando una singola query,
e non c'è errore. Assumendo che le operazioni
siano tutte fatte perfettamente, è corretto ogni singola volta.
Quindi come si confronta con
quello che possiamo fare classicamente?
Beh, se insistiamo su un algoritmo
deterministico che ottiene la risposta
corretta ogni singola volta, allora nel caso peggiore,
abbiamo bisogno di 2 alla n meno 1 più 1 query, e questo perché dobbiamo interrogare la funzione
su più della metà dei suoi input per essere certi della soluzione.
Anche se interroghiamo la funzione su 2 alla n meno 1
diverse stringhe di input, è possibile che vedremo lo stesso valore di output
ogni singola volta, e ciò potrebbe essere perché
la funzione è costante, oppure potrebbe essere bilanciata
e siamo stati semplicemente incredibilmente sfortunati ad aver visto lo stesso valore di output
ogni singola volta.
Quindi questo è un enorme vantaggio
del quantistico rispetto al classico, una singola query contro
esponenzialmente molte query.
Tuttavia, se usiamo un
algoritmo query probabilistico e accettiamo una piccola probabilità che risponda in modo errato,
allora in realtà ne servono solo poche query.
In particolare, se
scegliamo casualmente k stringhe e valutiamo la funzione
su quelle stringhe casuali,
allora è abbastanza probabile che saremo in grado di capire la risposta giusta.
In modo specifico, rispondiamo 0 o costante quando otteniamo lo stesso valore della funzione ogni singola volta e 1 o bilanciata
ogni volta che vediamo due
diversi valori della funzione.
Se lo facciamo, saremo sempre corretti quando
la funzione è costante perché, ovviamente, vedremo sempre lo stesso
valore di output in questo caso.
E se f è bilanciata, è molto probabile che vedremo
due diversi valori di output.
La possibilità che non vediamo
entrambi i valori di output in questo caso è la stessa di quella di lanciare una moneta k volte
e ottenere lo stesso
risultato ogni singola volta.
Quindi ad esempio, se
impostiamo k uguale a 11, la probabilità di ottenere una risposta sbagliata è inferiore a un decimo di percento.
Quindi soprattutto quando consideriamo il fatto che i computer quantistici non saranno mai perfetti nella realtà, non otteniamo un vantaggio così
grande qui,
ma stiamo facendo progressi, e abbiamo un vantaggio quantificabile del quantistico rispetto al classico che va oltre l'algoritmo di Deutsch.
Possiamo anche usare il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa per risolvere un diverso problema query noto come il problema di Bernstein-Vazirani.
Ecco un enunciato di quel problema. L'input è una funzione
da n bit a 1 bit, proprio come il problema di Deutsch-Jozsa,
e di nuovo, è un problema promise.
Questa volta, la promise è che esiste una qualche stringa di n bit s per cui la funzione f
funziona come vedi qui,
dove l'output è dato
dal prodotto punto binario dell'input con questa stringa s,
e l'obiettivo è semplicemente
trovare la stringa s. Quindi possiamo immaginare che la
stringa s sia nascosta in un certo senso,
ma possiamo imparare a riguardo
facendo query a f, e il nostro obiettivo è trovare
questa stringa nascosta.
Per essere chiari, la maggior parte delle funzioni
non soddisferà questa promise, ma come al solito, ci interessano solo le
funzioni di input che lo fanno.
Si scopre che il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa risolve effettivamente questo problema
direttamente.
Se lo eseguiamo per una
funzione come abbiamo qui che soddisfa la
promise per qualche stringa s, le misurazioni riveleranno la stringa s
senza nessuna post-elaborazione necessaria.
Quindi vediamo come funziona.
Abbiamo già analizzato
il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa, quindi possiamo effettivamente
saltare direttamente alla fine.
Ecco l'espressione che
avevamo prima per lo stato appena prima delle misurazioni, e quella espressione era
valida per qualsiasi funzione f.
E ora, se sostituiamo
quello che ci viene promesso sulla funzione f e semplificiamo,
otteniamo lo stato meno per il qubit in basso in prodotto tensoriale con cat s per i primi n qubit.
E quindi otteniamo s quando misuriamo.
C'è del lavoro da fare per eseguire le semplificazioni
che ho mostrato qui, e non lo farò in questo video,
ma c'è più dettaglio a riguardo nel contenuto del libro di testo di questa serie, che puoi trovare seguendo il link nella descrizione del video,
oppure provaci tu stesso
per un po' di pratica.
Quindi quello che abbiamo trovato è che
il circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa risolve il problema di Bernstein-Vazirani
con una singola query.
Non è troppo difficile dimostrare
che qualsiasi algoritmo classico, sia determinista
che probabilistico, ha bisogno di almeno n query
per risolvere il problema di Bernstein-Vazirani per il semplice motivo che abbiamo bisogno di n bit di
informazioni per recuperare s,
e ogni query ci dà al
massimo 1 bit di informazioni.
Quindi otteniamo un altro vantaggio del quantistico rispetto agli algoritmi query classici, una query per gli algoritmi quantistici,
n query per gli algoritmi classici.
Vale la pena prendere solo un momento per parlare della
nomenclatura usata nel contesto di questo problema e un po' della storia.
Le persone a volte si riferiscono all'algoritmo che ho appena descritto come l'algoritmo di Bernstein-Vazirani, ma in realtà è solo il
circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa,
e questo è qualcosa che è stato,
in effetti, molto chiaramente affermato nel lavoro di Bernstein e Vazirani.
Quindi è un po' strano che si chiami algoritmo di Bernstein-Vazirani perché è praticamente la stessa cosa dell'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa
meno la post-elaborazione. Bernstein e Vazirani hanno, tuttavia, fatto un passo avanti.
Hanno definito una versione ricorsiva
di questo problema, dove devi fondamentalmente
risolvere istanze del problema di Bernstein-Vazirani
per sbloccare nuove istanze del problema disposte in un
complicato schema ad albero.
È un problema altamente artificioso, ma il punto è che
definendo un problema in questo modo, potevano effettivamente estendere
la separazione di una contro n query tra quantistico e classico.
E quello che hanno ottenuto è
il primo esempio noto di un cosiddetto vantaggio super-polinomiale del quantistico rispetto agli algoritmi probabilistici.
Questa versione ricorsiva del problema di Bernstein-Vazirani si è anche rivelata molto più tardi
molto interessante nella teoria della complessità computazionale per ragioni diverse.
In ogni caso, il punto è che
Bernstein e Vazirani meritano certamente riconoscimento per i loro importanti contributi,
ma non ha davvero
senso riferirsi a questo come l'algoritmo di Bernstein-Vazirani, è fondamentalmente solo l'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa.
Nell'ultima parte della lezione, daremo uno sguardo a un altro
algoritmo di query quantistico noto come l'algoritmo di Simon.
Vedrai una chiara somiglianza
tra questo algoritmo e l'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa, ma è diverso, e più importante,
rivela un vantaggio molto più forte del quantistico rispetto agli algoritmi query
classici.
Nello specifico, ci dà un
vantaggio esponenziale provabile del quantistico rispetto agli algoritmi classici, anche quelli probabilistici.
Il problema che risolve è un po' artificiale, ed è difficile immaginare una situazione in cui risolvere questo
problema sarebbe utile,
ma ha direttamente ispirato
la scoperta di Peter Shor di un algoritmo quantistico
per la fattorizzazione degli interi,
e questo supporta molto fortemente
questa idea del modello query come piatto di Petri in cui le idee algoritmiche quantistiche
possono essere sviluppate.
Iniziamo con il problema query che l'algoritmo di Simon risolve, che, come potresti aver intuito,
si chiama problema di Simon.
Ecco un enunciato del problema, e dovremo scomporlo per capire di cosa si tratta.
La prima cosa da
notare è che questa volta, la funzione di input f mappa stringhe di n
bit a stringhe di m bit
dove m è qualche intero positivo che in generale non è uguale a uno.
È un problema promise. E come il problema di Bernstein-Vazirani, la promise coinvolge una qualche stringa s che possiamo vedere come una stringa nascosta,
e anche come il
problema di Bernstein-Vazirani, l'obiettivo è restituire
questa stringa nascosta s.
La promise è più
complicata questa volta però, quindi scomponiamola e
capiamo cosa sta dicendo.
Per iniziare, leggiamola. Dice che esiste una stringa s di lunghezza uguale a n
tale che una particolare condizione "se"
e "solo se" è vera per tutte le scelte di stringhe di n bit x e y.
Nello specifico, deve
essere il caso che f di x è uguale a f di y se e solo se una di
due possibilità vale.
La prima possibilità è che x è uguale a y, e la seconda possibilità è che prendendo l'OR esclusivo bit per bit di x
con la stringa nascosta s, otteniamo Y.
Questa risulta essere una
promise abbastanza stringente nel senso che la maggior parte
delle funzioni non la soddisferà.
Solo funzioni molto speciali
soddisfano questa condizione.
Ora, per capire meglio questa promise e quindi il problema stesso, considereremo due casi principali.
Il primo caso è che s
è la stringa di tutti zeri.
In questo caso, possiamo semplificare la dichiarazione "se"
e "solo se" nella promise perché l'OR esclusivo bit per bit di qualsiasi stringa x
con la stringa di tutti zeri
è semplicemente la stringa x.
Quindi la condizione si semplifica
a f di x è uguale a f di y se e solo se x è uguale a y.
E questo è solo un altro modo per dire che f è una funzione uno a uno.
In altre parole, la stringa f di x deve essere unica
per ogni possibile stringa x.
Quindi se f è una funzione uno a uno, allora la promise è davvero soddisfatta, nello specifico per s uguale
alla stringa di tutti zeri,
e in questo caso, quello è
l'output corretto.
Il secondo caso è che s
non è la stringa di tutti zeri, e quello che questo implica è che la funzione f deve essere due a uno.
Quindi per ogni stringa di input x, c'è esattamente un'altra stringa che f mappa alla stessa
stringa a cui x mappa,
e inoltre, l'altra stringa
deve essere la stringa che otteniamo prendendo l'OR esclusivo bit per bit di x con s.
Un altro modo per dirlo
è che ogni stringa di n bit x ha un partner, e quel partner è la stringa che otteniamo
prendendo l'OR esclusivo bit per bit con s.
Qualsiasi due partner devono darci
la stessa stringa di output se li inseriamo in f, e nessun'altra stringa è autorizzata a darci
quella stessa stringa di output.
Quindi queste sono necessariamente stringhe distinte che i partner producono.
Ecco un esempio di una funzione del genere descritta dalla sua tabella di valori.
Quindi questa è una funzione
da 3 bit a 5 bit.
Se fissiamo questa tabella
di valori per un po', troviamo che la promise è
soddisfatta per la stringa 011.
000 e 011 sono partner. Facendo XOR di uno di essi
per s ci dà l'altro,
e hanno lo stesso valore di output, che è 10011 in questo caso particolare, e nessun'altra stringa produce
quella stessa stringa di output.
001 e 010 sono partner perché facendo XOR di uno di essi
per s si ottiene l'altro, e producono lo stesso valore di output,
che di nuovo, non è prodotto
da nessun'altra stringa.
E la situazione è
simile per 100 e 111 così come 101 e 110.
Quindi se l'input del
problema è questa funzione, la risposta corretta è la stringa 011.
Come ho detto prima, la maggior parte delle funzioni non soddisfa questa promise, è una condizione molto specifica.
Va anche notato che
se la promise è soddisfatta, può essere soddisfatta solo per una stringa s.
Quindi c'è sempre solo una
risposta corretta a questo problema.
Quindi questo è il problema di Simon. Come ho detto, è difficile immaginare una situazione pratica in cui vorresti risolvere questo problema,
ma questo è secondario. Il punto è cercare di capire in cosa sono bravi i computer quantistici, e si scopre che sono di gran lunga superiori
agli algoritmi classici per
risolvere questo particolare problema.
Ora diamo uno sguardo
all'algoritmo di Simon, che risolve il problema di Simon.
L'algoritmo consiste nel
eseguire il circuit quantistico che vedi qui diverse volte, seguito da una
fase di post-elaborazione classica,
e saremo più specifici su cosa significa diverse
volte un po' più avanti.
Il circuit sembra molto simile
al circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa, questa volta perché la funzione
f mappa n bit a m bit,
il gate di query è diverso. Invece di solo un singolo
qubit in basso, ora abbiamo m qubit in basso
e n in alto come prima.
Una differenza fondamentale è che non
stiamo impostando uno stato meno o più stati meno in basso.
Questi qubit in basso sono tutti
inizializzati allo stato 0, e quegli stati vanno direttamente
nel gate di query.
Quindi non ci sarà nessun phase kickback coinvolto in questo algoritmo, non è semplicemente come funziona questo.
A parte le differenze
che ho appena menzionato però, sembra molto simile al
circuit di Deutsch-Jozsa.
Applichiamo uno strato di gate Hadamard, poi applichiamo un gate di query una volta, e poi applichiamo un altro
strato di gate Hadamard
seguito da misurazioni della base standard dei primi n qubit.
L'idea è che ogni volta che
eseguiamo questo circuit e misuriamo, otterremo una qualche stringa y che ci dice qualcosa
sulla stringa nascosta s
nel problema di Simon. E eseguendo il circuit
diverse volte indipendentemente, avremo raccolto abbastanza
evidenza statistica su s
da essere in grado di capire cosa
è con alta confidenza.
Ora analizziamo il circuit quantistico
per l'algoritmo di Simon per vedere cosa fa.
Lo stato dopo il primo
strato di gate Hadamard ha questo aspetto, simile a quello che avevamo per
l'algoritmo di Deutsch-Jozsa.
Tranne che questa volta, gli m qubit in basso sono tutti nello stato 0
invece di essere in stati meno.
Dopo che il gate di query viene eseguito, vediamo che il valore f di x è stato scritto sui
qubit più in basso o più a sinistra,
e questo perché f di x è stato fatto XOR sulla stringa di tutti zeri.
Quindi di nuovo, non c'è nessun phase kickback che accade in questo algoritmo.
Poi eseguiamo il secondo
strato di gate Hadamard.
E usando la stessa formula di prima per l'azione di uno
strato di gate Hadamard su uno stato della base
standard, cat x in questo caso,
come era nella formula originale, otteniamo questo stato qui, dove l'azione dei gate Hadamard
è stata resa più apparente. Ma se vogliamo, possiamo anche scrivere lo stato
in una forma più compatta come abbiamo qui.
A questo punto, misuriamo i primi n qubit per ottenere qualche stringa di n bit y, e dobbiamo solo capire
quali sono le probabilità
per le diverse stringhe. E questo ci aiuterà a capire
quali informazioni otteniamo da questa stringa y sulla stringa s
nascosta all'interno della funzione f.
Avremo bisogno di
più spazio per questo, e non abbiamo davvero più bisogno
del diagramma del circuit, quindi disfacciamocene e diamo a noi stessi più
spazio per l'analisi.
Ecco lo stato appena
prima delle misurazioni, che sono misurazioni della base standard dei primi o più a destra n qubit.
Quindi la misurazione
corrisponde al secondo cat.
Denotiamo con p di y, la probabilità che le misurazioni ci diano la stringa y per ogni possibile y.
E se seguiamo le regole della Lezione 2, otteniamo che ciascuna di queste probabilità è la norma euclidea al quadrato di qualsiasi vettore tensoriale
allo stato della base standard,
corrispondente a perché nel
nostro vettore di stato quantistico.
Questo ci dà questa espressione qui.
Ora, per capire meglio
queste probabilità, dovremo usare alcune notazioni, e potresti già conoscere questa notazione
perché è abbastanza comune in matematica.
Prima, quando ci riferiamo all'
immagine della funzione f, intendiamo semplicemente l'insieme di tutte le stringhe che possono uscire da questa funzione.
Quindi è l'insieme di tutti i f di x al variare di tutte le possibili
scelte di una stringa di input x.
Secondo, useremo questa notazione che vedi qui per indicare l'insieme di tutte le stringhe di input x
che f mappa a una data stringa z, per qualsiasi scelta di
z che vogliamo considerare.
Sembra un po' l'inversa della funzione f, ma non è davvero l'inversa perché f non è necessariamente invertibile.
Vediamo anche che abbiamo
un insieme come argomento sul lato sinistro, e in questo caso, è l'insieme contenente
solo una singola stringa z,
e questo è il suggerimento di cui abbiamo bisogno per riconoscere che non stiamo parlando
dell'inversa della funzione f, questa si chiama pre-immagine.
La pre-immagine può essere
definita più in generale per qualsiasi insieme dato come argomento, non solo l'insieme contenente
un singolo elemento,
ma questo è tutto ciò di cui avremo bisogno. Non è la migliore
notazione del mondo perché è facile
confonderla con l'inversa,
ma è abbastanza chiara
ed è ampiamente usata, quindi la useremo.
E ora se usiamo questa notazione, possiamo riscrivere il vettore di cui stiamo prendendo la norma euclidea al quadrato per ottenere la probabilità per
la misurazione di ogni stringa y.
Lo stiamo facendo perché dobbiamo vedere
quali sono i coefficienti per ogni singolo stato della base standard, e ciò non è chiaro da
questa espressione qui,
perché, in generale, potremmo avere
più scelte di x che ci danno la stessa stringa f di x.
In sostanza, tutto quello che stiamo facendo
è dividere la somma su x prima sommando su tutti i
z nell'immagine di f,
e poi all'interno di quella somma, sommando su tutti i x nella pre-immagine di z, o per essere più precisi,
la pre-immagine dell'insieme
contenente la stringa z.
Ciò ci permette di sostituire f di x con z all'interno del cat qui.
E la somma su tutte le diverse stringhe
x che f mappa a ciascuna z vengono raccolte nel
coefficiente per ogni cat.
Stiamo fondamentalmente mettendo le stringhe in contenitori, sommando sui contenitori, e poi sommando
le stringhe in ogni contenitore,
ma questo equivale a solo
sommare su tutte le stringhe.
Quindi otteniamo un'espressione che è equivalente a quella
con cui abbiamo iniziato,
e ora possiamo calcolare la
norma euclidea al quadrato.
È solo la somma dei quadrati dei valori assoluti
dei coefficienti, e quindi, otteniamo questa espressione qui
per le nostre probabilità.
Ovviamente, datti
il tempo di verificare questo, se scegli di farlo, ci vuole tempo per abituarsi a tutto questo
e per essere in grado di eseguire
questi calcoli, e più pratica ti dai, più diventerà facile.
Finora, non abbiamo effettivamente
usato la promise nel problema di Simon.
La nostra analisi di queste probabilità funziona in realtà per qualsiasi funzione f, ma ora è il momento di pensare al problema di Simon
nello specifico.
Scomporremo le cose negli stessi due casi
che avevamo prima.
Il primo caso è che s
è la stringa di tutti zeri, e il secondo caso è che
s non è la stringa di tutti zeri.
Nel primo caso, che
s è la stringa di tutti zeri, le cose sono abbastanza semplici.
In questo caso, come abbiamo visto prima, abbiamo che f è una funzione uno a uno, quindi c'è una singola stringa x
che viene mappata a ciascuna delle
stringhe z nell'immagine di f.
Questo rende il valore assoluto al quadrato della somma su quelle stringhe uguale a 1 perché c'è solo un
singolo termine nella somma,
è più 1 o meno 1, ma non importa quale perché prendiamo il
valore assoluto al quadrato, e quindi otteniamo uno.
Ci sono 2 alla n
elementi nell'immagine di f, e lo sappiamo perché f è uno a uno, quindi c'è una stringa nell'
immagine per ogni stringa di input.
E se valutiamo l'intera espressione, troviamo che ogni stringa y appare con probabilità
uno su due alla n.
Quindi in altre parole, le
misurazioni ci danno una stringa y scelta uniformemente a caso.
Potrebbe non sembrare molto utile, ma in realtà saremo in grado
di distinguere questo comportamento dal comportamento che otteniamo nel caso
che s non sia la stringa di tutti zeri, e vedremo come va tra poco.
Per ora però, osserviamo semplicemente che se
f soddisfa la promise nel problema di Simon nel caso che s è la stringa di tutti zeri,
allora il risultato delle misurazioni è una stringa casuale uniforme.
Ora passiamo al secondo caso, che è che la promise
è soddisfatta per una stringa s che non è la stringa di tutti zeri.
In questo caso, come abbiamo discusso prima, ogni stringa z nell'immagine di f ha esattamente due stringhe che si mappano su di essa,
perché ogni stringa ha un partner, e ogni coppia di partner
mappa a qualche stringa unica, e nello specifico, il partner di ogni stringa
è la stringa che otteniamo facendo XOR con s.
Quindi se scegliamo qualsiasi stringa
z nell'immagine di f, e diamo il nome w a una delle
stringhe che f mappa a z,
allora l'XOR di w con s è l'
altra stringa che mappa a z.
Guardando solo il termine nella nostra somma che corrisponde a qualsiasi stringa z nell'immagine che abbiamo in mente,
vediamo che possiamo
scriverlo più esplicitamente come abbiamo qui.
Abbiamo due stringhe nella pre-immagine di z, w e w XOR con s.
Quindi possiamo scrivere la somma
come vedi sullo schermo, e ora quello che possiamo fare è estrarre un fattore di
meno 1 alla potenza w.y.
Quel fattore sarà
più 1 o meno 1, quindi scompare quando
prendiamo il valore assoluto,
e quello con cui rimaniamo è
questa espressione qui.
I dettagli non sono tutti mostrati qui, e non è necessariamente
ovvio che funzioni in questo modo, ma puoi verificare che queste
due espressioni siano uguali
tornando alla definizione
del prodotto punto binario e pensando a cosa succede quando queste cose sono nell'esponente di meno 1,
non diversamente da quello che avevamo per il
problema di Bernstein-Vazirani.
Infine, possiamo dividere questa
espressione in due casi.
È 4 quando il prodotto punto binario
di s e y è 0, e è 0 quando il prodotto punto
binario di s e y è 1.
Nota in particolare che
non c'è nessuna dipendenza qui su w o z, dipende solo da s e y.
Il motivo per cui questo accade è
a causa della natura molto specifica e particolare della promise.
In sostanza, questo è il motivo per cui la promise è stata formulata in questo modo, così che tutto si risolvesse in questo modo.
Di nuovo, ogni stringa ha un partner, che otteniamo facendo XOR con
questa unica stringa nascosta s,
ed è questo che fa sì che tutto questo accada.
Ora possiamo tornare all'
espressione per le probabilità e inserire le cose.
Quando s non è la stringa di tutti zeri, ci sono 2 alla n meno 1
elementi nell'immagine di f,
che è la metà del
numero di stringhe di input, e inserendo i
valori che abbiamo appena calcolato ci dà questa formula qui.
Quindi questa volta, y non è una
stringa completamente casuale, ma piuttosto y è uniforme esattamente su metà delle stringhe di n bit,
e nello specifico, è
uniforme su quelle stringhe che hanno il prodotto punto binario uguale a 0 con s.
Ora che sappiamo come funziona il circuit
per l'algoritmo di Simon e nello specifico quali
sono le probabilità per i diversi risultati di misurazione,
rimane da spiegare come questo ci aiuta a risolvere il problema di Simon.
Riassumendo quello che abbiamo appena appreso, se è il caso che la funzione f soddisfi la promise nel problema di Simon,
quando la stringa nascosta s
è la stringa di tutti zeri, otteniamo una stringa completamente casuale
dalle misurazioni,
dove ogni stringa y di n bit
è ugualmente probabile.
Se d'altra parte, la funzione f soddisfa la promise per una diversa stringa s, una che non è uguale
alla stringa di tutti zeri,
allora otteniamo una stringa casuale y con prodotto punto binario
uguale a 0 con s, e tra tutte quelle stringhe,
ogni y è ugualmente probabile.
Ma non otterremo mai una stringa y con prodotto punto binario
uguale a 1 con s.
La domanda diventa, "È questo sufficiente informazione
per determinare s?" E la risposta, come ho già
suggerito, è sì,
purché eseguiamo il
circuit abbastanza volte.
Nello specifico, supponiamo
che eseguiamo il circuit k volte, dove K è uguale a n più r,
dove r è qualche numero che controllerà la
probabilità che recuperiamo s.
Solo come esempio, se
scegliamo r uguale a 10, avremo successo con
probabilità superiore al 99.9%,
quindi r non deve essere poi così grande.
In generale, la probabilità di fallimento è inferiore alla probabilità
di lanciare una moneta equa r volte e ottenere testa ogni singola volta.
Quindi se il 99.9% non è sufficiente,
allora prendi r uguale a 20, e la possibilità di fallimento è
inferiore a uno su un milione,
o scegli qualsiasi r
che ti fa sentire a tuo agio. Non puoi garantire una soluzione corretta, ma puoi rendere la
probabilità di errore trascurabile
a tutti gli effetti pratici.
Qui stiamo nominando queste
stringhe y1 attraverso yk, dove usiamo apici per aiutarci a nominare queste stringhe,
solo così possiamo riservare i pedici per riferirci ai singoli
bit di quelle stringhe.
Quindi questi non sono esponenti
o altro del genere, questi sono solo i nomi che stiamo dando a queste k stringhe.
Ognuna ha lunghezza n perché le abbiamo ottenute
eseguendo il circuit per l'algoritmo di Simon.
Quindi possiamo scrivere i
singoli bit di queste k stringhe come vedi qui.
Quello che facciamo ora è creare una matrice m, dove ogni voce di questa matrice è un bit, e otteniamo questi bit dalle stringhe
che abbiamo appena misurato, come mostrato qui.
Quindi questa matrice ha k righe e n colonne, e le sue voci sono tutte valori binari.
Ora, non sappiamo qual è s. Questo è quello che stiamo cercando di trovare, ma immagina per un
momento che lo sapessimo,
e formassimo un vettore colonna
dai bit di s, come è mostrato qui.
Se dovessimo moltiplicare quel vettore per m e poi prendere il risultato modulo-2, o un altro modo per dirlo
è che sostituiamo l'addizione
con l'OR esclusivo, allora otterremo necessariamente
il vettore di tutti zeri.
Questo perché ciascuna delle
voci in questo vettore risultante non è altro che il
prodotto punto binario di s
con una delle righe di m.
Se S capita di essere la stringa di tutti zeri, otterremo sempre il vettore zero dal prodotto punto binario.
E se s non è la stringa di tutti zeri, lo otterremo da quello che
sappiamo sulle probabilità per le stringhe y1 attraverso yk di apparire.
In particolare, il
prodotto punto binario con s è sempre zero per tutte queste stringhe.
Un modo semplice per dirlo è che questo vettore
formato dai bit di s è sempre nel nucleo della matrice m,
assumendo che stiamo facendo tutta
la nostra aritmetica modulo-2, ma ovviamente, non sappiamo qual è s,
stiamo cercando s.
Ma quello che possiamo fare è calcolare il
nucleo di questa matrice m, ancora una volta, modulo-2.
Nello specifico, possiamo farlo usando la tecnica dell'
eliminazione gaussiana, che è la procedura spesso insegnata
nei corsi introduttivi di algebra lineare.
Funziona perfettamente quando facciamo tutta la nostra aritmetica modulo-2, e può essere fatto abbastanza
efficientemente con un computer.
E se calcoliamo il nucleo di m, dato il modo specifico in cui queste k stringhe sono state
scelte casualmente,
saremo in grado di recuperare s con probabilità superiore a
1 meno 2 alla meno r.
Per essere specifici, quello che vedremo con probabilità superiore a
1 meno 2 alla meno r è che il nucleo include il vettore di tutti zeri,
come fa sempre per ogni matrice, così come il vettore corrispondente a s, sia esso il vettore di tutti zeri o no.
E più importante, nessun altro vettore apparirà nel nucleo.
In realtà non è troppo difficile dimostrarlo, anche se non lo farò in dettaglio.
In realtà non è troppo difficile dimostrarlo, sebbene non lo farò nel dettaglio.
L'idea è che se abbiamo
un'altra stringa che non è il vettore di tutti zeri
e non è s, allora ciascuna delle stringhe casuali, y1 attraverso yk,
la eliminerà fondamentalmente dal nucleo con probabilità un mezzo.
Quindi dopo k esecuzioni, non è
per niente probabile che sopravviva, e in effetti, nessuna delle
stringhe che non appartengono
è probabile che sopravviva. E un fatto molto semplice
dalla teoria della probabilità, noto come il bound dell'unione, può
essere usato per stabilire questo.
Non ho spiegato tutti
i dettagli qui, ma speriamo che tu abbia l'idea che calcolando il nucleo modulo-2 di questa matrice m,
è molto probabile che recuperiamo s, e questo è il modo in cui l'algoritmo di Simon
risolve il problema di Simon.
C'è solo una cosa rimasta
da dire sul problema di Simon, e riguarda la
difficoltà classica di questo problema,
cioè, quante query ha bisogno un algoritmo query classico per risolvere il problema di Simon?
La risposta è, molte, in generale.
Ci sono diversi enunciati precisi
che possono essere fatti sulla difficoltà classica di questo problema, ed ecco solo uno di essi.
Se abbiamo qualsiasi algoritmo query probabilistico
e quell'algoritmo fa meno di 2 alla potenza n su 2
meno 1, meno 1 query,
quindi un numero di query
che è esponenziale in n, allora quell'algoritmo fallirà
a risolvere il problema di Simon,
con probabilità almeno un mezzo.
A volte, dimostrare
risultati di impossibilità come questo può essere molto difficile, ma questo non è troppo difficile da dimostrare
attraverso un'analisi probabilistica
elementare.
Non lo farò in questa lezione video, e mi concentrerò invece solo
sull'intuizione dietro.
Stiamo cercando di trovare la stringa nascosta s, ma finché non interroghiamo la funzione su due stringhe con
lo stesso valore di output,
otterremo informazioni molto limitate
su s.
Fondamentalmente, tutto quello che impariamo è
che la stringa nascosta s non è l'OR esclusivo di due qualsiasi
stringhe distinte che abbiamo interrogato,
E se interroghiamo la funzione con meno di questo numero di query, ci saranno ancora molte scelte di s
che non sono state escluse.
Questa non è una dimostrazione formale,
ma questa è l'idea di base.
Quindi in sintesi, l'algoritmo di Simon ci fornisce un sorprendente vantaggio del quantistico rispetto agli algoritmi classici
all'interno del modello query.
In particolare, l'algoritmo di Simon
risolve il problema di Simon con un numero di query che è lineare nel numero di bit di input
n alla nostra funzione,
mentre qualsiasi algoritmo classico,
anche se probabilistico, deve fare un numero di
query che è esponenziale in n
per risolvere il problema di Simon con una ragionevole probabilità di successo.
È vero che il problema di Simon è un problema alquanto artificiale che presumibilmente nessuno
vuole davvero risolvere,
ma questo è secondario. A volte le idee devono essere sviluppate prima di essere messe in pratica.
E in effetti, Peter Shor ha chiaramente affermato che è stato l'algoritmo di Simon ad ispirare il suo ormai
famoso algoritmo quantistico
per la fattorizzazione degli interi, che vedremo tra un paio di lezioni.
E questa è la fine della Lezione 5.
In questa lezione, abbiamo dato uno sguardo al
modello query di calcolo, e abbiamo visto una progressione di esempi
di algoritmi quantistici
che esibiscono vantaggi rispetto agli algoritmi classici
all'interno di questo modello.
C'è, in effetti, molto di più
noto sul modello query e sugli algoritmi quantistici per altri problemi che
non ho discusso.
Quindi se trovi questo
modello interessante, c'è molto di più
da imparare su di esso.
Il nostro prossimo passo sarà allontanarci dal modello query e verso un modello di calcolo
più rappresentativo
dei tipi di problemi che speriamo di risolvere in pratica.
Spero che ti unirai a me per la Lezione 6, dove ci concentreremo principalmente su
gettare una base per lo studio degli algoritmi quantistici.
E da lì, passeremo ad alcuni
algoritmi quantistici specifici, tra cui l'algoritmo di Shor
per la fattorizzazione degli interi
nelle lezioni successive. Arrivederci alla prossima!